so yes sir oh I'm sorry I got let me
take the guy that's if the microphone
and then somebody to bring a microphone
over to yes um ken Howard classes 716
call again hey how are you coach a
softball could you just talk for a
second about the improvements of the
Baker field and the commitment at
university athletics yes I don't want
bill talking about this so did I never
get a chance yeah so I said when I
started that it was unacceptable to have
losing athletic program and this is
there's not something we should be proud
of it's something that we should correct
then I brought in bill campbell and Bill
Campbell of course he's responsible for
all the winning teams I'm responsible
and Bill has I mean he is just devoted
to himself to this among many other
things and helped as always to nurture
coaches and to help diane murphy whom I
brought in as the athletic director and
and and we have a new we have a strategy
not only with respect to the teams but
how to do this and the strategy diane
murphy and others came up with was we
don't have a problem of facilities
they're great facilities up at the Baker
Athletic Complex they're just not
adequate in terms of what they provide
our student-athletes and so we need it
first of all we need a major sports
center there for students be able to
relax study work and socialize and work
out and as a symbol of just how
important this is to us to the
University and how important bill is to
all of this we're naming the
Center after Bill Campbell and the
groundbreaking
the groundbreaking was a week ago and
within a short period of time you'll see
this magnificent building designed by
Steven Holl one of our architects in the
school of architecture urban planning
one of the great world's architects so
we're making great progress really I
think I've forgotten now the number of
ivy league championships we have but
we're no longer at the bottom of that
list we're really right in the thick of
the Ivy League so people want to know
all I got from coaching to haight tacky
and my answers always did you ever see
my record don't laugh so hard come on so
we're going to take one more question
George yes you were you were first in
fact it's one thing to tap the alumni
network for capital and contribution but
there's a lot of other resources
particularly as people are living longer
as the economy has kind of created very
experienced people out there that could
contribute not only through their
experience but teaching other ways are
working with people yep what are the
university's plans along this regard to
sort of tap other resources from the
alums well I think of course that's
absolutely right and I there's so many
ways in which a very vibrant alumni body
is meaningful to the institution you
know it's all the time we are sending
faculty and administrators Dean's and so
on out into the world to talk to alums I
think every single one of those people
would say we really learn a lot about
how to manage run the institution so
there is a massive amount of interaction
that's really extremely beneficial
there are very important roles in
helping us identify new students I mean
this is a this is our lifeblood this is
why we do this we really want the best
young people and most deserving young
people in the United States and around
the world and alumni are crucial to
helping that happen persuading people to
come helping them prepare to come
helping them when they're here and the
like then there's the issue of how to
engage the alumni more in the kind of
teaching within the institution many
schools of course draw on alums as as
visiting faculty or adjunct faculty
that's extremely important but I think
the one place we we haven't really
successfully yet built up is how do we
connect on an ongoing basis using modern
technology so that you feel part of the
educational excitement of the place if
you if you took me off the stage here
and bill and brought up a group of
faculty to talk about their field you
know the effect that has you you just
feel the incredible excitement of
knowledge in the process of being
created these are everybody in this
faculty is just so gifted at being able
to think about things and communicate it
and define what our problems are but how
to create and they do that in the
classroom how to get that excitement of
the classroom and the experience of
being in a university on the web open to
alums to participate in that I think is
the great future and we're still just at
the very very beginning of that and we
would welcome I think ideas and thoughts
about that so I'm going to close with a
couple of a couple quick remarks one
I can't tell you how lucky we are and
all of us should feel this way that we
have laid Bollinger's our president
except that second and you know
important is you know that the fact that
you're all here in this room with a a
wonderful comma after your name that
says CAA is just fantastic and this a
vision of Susan Susan Fagan Richard
Witten and nobody's walking around
putting their hand in your pocket this
is something that that when you heard
gotta McPhee on that video say this is
about connecting people we want you too
can we want to connect you with each
other and we want to connect you with
Columbia and nothing she could not have
said anything better she's a phenomenal
leader you heard the names that came up
Steve Case who was the first trustee to
take this on and there's the first chair
Jim you've had been familiar with him
for some time and now you know as much
as I hate to admit it George is pretty
good he has been such a good friend for
so many years and and he will be a
fantastic chair but I just know that
with George and Fred Van Sickle we've
got you know the right team with all of
you in this room we can continue to
expand this organization in terms of
numbers in geography I know we can do
this we've got a great leader here we've
got a great leader there we're in good
shape so thank you very much for happen
thank you very much